les services essentiels en temps de
pandémie ce n'est pas une raison pour
profiter de la situation au détriment de
ses clients
je vais vous raconter l'histoire de
madame c'est ire de boucherville qui a
eu des problèmes avec un plombier
madame cyr découvre un dégât d'eau dans
son appartement
suite à la rupture d'un tuyau à
l'intérieur de ses murs alors en
catastrophe
elle appelle le 1er plombier qu'elle
trouve sur internet et oublient de lui
demander son tarif horaire savez vous
combien ce plombier a demandé à madame
cyr pour deux heures de travail 700 $ ce
qui veut dire 350 $ l'heure vous avez
bien compris et ce en plus des 90
dollars pour le déplacement et des 400
dollars de matériel ce qui fait en tout
et pour tout une facture de plus de 1300
dollars madame cyr n'en revenais pas
elle a tenté de négocier avec le
plombier pour faire baisser cette
facture mais le plombier n'a rien voulu
entendre
il lui a dit qu'il avait des dépenses
supplémentaires à assumer en raison de
lakovic 19
madame cyr fait appel à la corporation
des maîtres mécaniciens en tuyauterie du
québec c'est la corporation des
plombiers et cette corporation peut
intervenir en votre faveur auprès du
professionnel pour tenter de faire
baisser la facture lorsque vous la
trouvez abusive
c'est ce qu'on appelle la conciliation
de compte la corporation des maîtres
électriciens offre le même service
la chambre des notaires aussi le barreau
du québec aussi et dans le cas de madame
sears a eu de très bons résultats parce
que le plombier a accepté de payer ses
factures 400 dollars 460 $ avec les
taxes ce qui ramène son tarif horaire de
350 à 150 dans leurs conclusions
deux petits conseils n'oubliez pas
qu'ils eurent ce service de conciliation
de compte qui est offert par la
corporation d'un professionnel et aussi
lorsque vous appelez un plombier ou un
électricien
demandez-lui son tarif horaire à 20
qu'il arrive chez vous